[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في الاسبوع الماضي
عاد نائب الرئيس ورئيس الوزراء اليمني
خالد بحاح الى عدن رفقه سبعه من وزراء
حكومته بعد ذلك ايام وتحديدا يوم الثلاثاء
عاد الرئيس عبد ربو منصور هادي الى عدن
بعد غياب دام قرابه السته اشهر نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما الذي يعنيه وصول الرئيس اليمني
لعدن في هذا التوقيت وبعد فتره من
الغياب ما الذي يمكن ان تحققه هذه الخطوه
على الصعيدين الميداني والسياسي في الفتره
المقبله
بعد وصوله عدن تراس الرئيس اليمني عبد ربو
منصور هادي اجتماعا للحكومه تعهد فيه بدعم
المقاومه الشعبيه وفتح معسكرات لاستيعاب
عناصرها في قطاعات الامن والجيش كما ثمن
دور دول التحالف العربي وفي مقدمتها
السعوديه واعتبر هادي ان عودته الى عدن
بمثابه مرحله اساسيه على طريق استعاده
السلطه الشرعيه وتحرير بقيه المناطق التي
لا تزال بايدي الحوثيين ونقلت وكاله سبانت
عن هذه قوله ان العوده الى العاصمه صنعاء
ستكون قريبه تقرير زياد
بركات بعودته الى عدن تصبح صنعاء واقرب لا
جغرافيا بل سياسيا ورمزيه يعرف هذ ذلك بعد
نحو سته شهور قضاها في الجوار السعودي من
هناك راقب الرجل مدن بلاده ومحافظاتها
تسحب من تحت قدميه كما راقب من مكانه
البعيد تلك المدن تستعاد بال مقاومه
وبتدخل التحالف العسكري اعيدت عدن واستعيد
وعادت وهو في الخارج خمس محافظات كبرى
عادت واعيدت من قبضه الحوثيين رئيس وزرائه
عاد فلم يبقى سوى ان يعود الرئيس نفسه وهو
ما كان تبدو استراتيجيه هادي واضحه عدن
فارب وتعز وصنعاء في نهايه المطاف وهي
ايضا استراتيجيه قوات التحالف التي يعتبر
البعض عوده هادي نفسه نقله مفصليه فيها
واحد انجازاتها
في مارب القتال يحتدم فعليا ثمت وحسب بضعه
فلول للحوثيين لكن هؤلاء ليسوا في اي مكان
هناك بل في اكثر مناطق مارب استراتيجيه
انهم يسيطرون على الطريق الذي يصلها
بصنعاء ولجعل الطريق الى العاصمه سالكه
يتوجب دحرهم من هناك ودفعهم الى معاقلهم
الاولى في صنعاء وصعده في تعز الاوضاع
اسوا وهي لا تسر رئيسا عاد من الرياض بعد
غياب ف المدينه تتعرض بين حين واخر الى
قصف حوثي عنيف وبالغ القسوه والعشوائيه
معا وثمت ما يقول يمنيون انها ماساه
انسانيه تتفاقم هناك فضحايا قصف الحوثيين
من المدنيين في غالبيتهم وثمت نقص فادح في
الدواء والطعام والماء ما يضاعف من اهميه
حسم الاوضاع كما يضاعف من مسؤوليه القياده
اليمنيه ازاء شعبها في الاسراع بحسم
الصراع عسكريا للتقليل من الاثمان
الانسانيه الباهظه التي تدفع تلك من شانها
نقل عوده الرئيس هادي من خانه الرمزيه الى
خانه الاستراتيجيه والامر نفسه ينطبق على
مارب هناك قوات التحالف ومسلح المقاومه
ومن هناك يفترض ان تبدا معركه صنعاء وذاك
كما يقول اليمنيون ما سرع في عوده الرئيس
باعتبارها خطوه اساسيه لاستكمال الشرعيه
ومنح اي خطوات كبرى ومصيري لقوات التحالف
شرعيه تمنح من فوق الارض اليمن
لا من خارجها شرعيه تقود كما يريد يمنيون
وهي في الميدان او على مقربه منه وتتقدم
بالتزامن مع تقدم قوات التحالف فاذا هي في
صنعاء لا ان تهبط عليها من احدى مروحيات
التحالف موضوع حلقه هذه الليله نناقشه مع
ضيفين من عدن الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبد
الناصر العربي ومن لندن الكاتب والباحث
السياسي اليمني محمد جميح نبدا من عدن
والسيد عبد الناصر العربي
ونبدا في الواقع نود ان نفهم عوده الرئيس
عبد ربو منصور هادي في هذا التوقيت هل
التوقيت له اهميه ما هل باعتقادك تاخر
كثيرا ام انه وصل في الوقت
المناسب بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اولا اهنئكم بعيد الفطر المبارك
العالمين العربي والاسلامي كل عام وانت
بخير وتطرق الى هذا الموضوع الهام وطرق
الى لهذا الموضوع الهام والذي كان شائكا
والان بدات ينابيع الخير منه تتفكك
وتبزيع
رساله واضحه لكافه الاطراف وعلى راسها
طرفي القتل والتدمير وعشاق الموت
المتواجدين في العاصمه اليمني الحبيبه
صنعاء واؤكد بان الاخ رئيس الجمهوريه
عودته جاءت ب قد تكون متاخره ولكنها اتت
ولتقوم بدور فاعل نحو بناء مستقبلي لابد
منه والاخ رئيس الجمهوريه انا متاكد بانه
جاء يحمل ملفات يريد ان ينفذها على الارض
ولكن هذه الملفات تحتاج ان نكون جميعا مع
بعضنا البعض متراصين والا لن نكون ناجحين
في الافق الذي نتمناه ا اتحول الان للسيد
محمد جميح الرئيس هذه اثر العوده الى عدن
ثم سيغادر بعد ايام قليله الى نيويورك هل
ترى في هذه الرمزيه او هذه الخطوه اهميه
ما ورساله ما للمجتمع الدولي الذي ربما
سيتوجه اليه بالكلام في
نيويورك اولا كل عام وانتم بخير جميعا
وبنسبه لعوده الرئيس هادي الى عدن لا شك
انه على المستوى المحلي قبل الدولي خبر
سيء بالنسبه لجماعه صالح
والحوثي الذين كانوا راهنوا واقسموا
الايمان المغلظه وتعهدوا بان يمنعوه من
العوده الى وطنه هاهو قد عاد وهذا هذه
العوده تعد بالنسبه لهذه او بالنسبه
لمشروع الانقلابيين عفوا مسمار ربما او
احد المسامير الاخيره في نعش
الانقلاب خاصه وان هذه سيغا بعد ايام من
عدن متجها الى نيويورك عوده هادي بالامس
الى عدن اضفت عليه مزيدا من الشرعيه
الشعبيه بالاضافه الى الشرعيه السياسيه
لكن انتقاله من عدن الى نيويورك يعني
ذهابه من ارض الوطن من ترابه الوطني الى
المنبر الدولي وليس من الرياض الى المنبر
الدولي كما يحاول المروجون ان يقولوا بانه
رئيس في المنفى وانه لا يمتلك الصلاحيات
وما الى ذلك هو الان يتحرك من عدن من
ترابه الى المنبر الدولي واعتقد ان صوره
هذه متربعا على اي منصه الامم المتحده
ومخاط العالم بما جرى لوطنه من احداث خلال
الفتره الماضيه سوف تكون سيئه بالنسبه
لصالح والحوثيين الذين كانوا قد حلموا بان
هذه قد انتهى من القاموس السياسي والوطني
اليمني وها هو يعود اليهم مره اخرى وينطلق
مره اخرى من عدن الى نيويورك ليخاطب
العالم في شرعيه او تا اكيد شرعيه الدوليه
التي يحاول الانقلابيون في صنعاء ان يتنصل
منها على اهميه هذه العوده والانطلاق كما
ذكرت من عدن لمخاطبه العالم في نيويورك ما
الاولويات التي هي مطروحه الان على جدول
اعمال هادي ليحققها في نهايه الامر في عدن
وباقي المناطق
اليمنيه طبعا انا اعتقد ان عوده الرئيس
هادي على الرغم من اهميه ها لكنها ستكون
ستواجه بصعوبات جمه هناك ملفات هائله
وثقيله في عدن تنتظر الرئيس هادي لعل
الملف الانساني هو الملف الملح في الفتره
الراهنه سواء كان في عدن او في المحافظات
المجاوره لعدن او كان في محافظات
الجمهوريه باكملها هذا ملف والملف الاخر
وهو ملف ايضا خطير الملف الامني لانه بعد
تحرير عدن من قبضه الحوثيين هناك بعض
النتوءات الامنيه والخروقات هنا وهناك
التي تومئ وت يشير الى ان الوضع الامني في
عدن لم يصل درجه درجه الكمال في الاستتباب
وبالتالي اتصور ان دمج المقاومين ضمن بنيه
الجيش والامن مهم لاستقرار الاوضاع في عدن
وفي غيرها من المدن كما ان الملف العسكري
ايضا يلقي بظلاله على عوده الرئيس هادي
تعز لا تزال ترزح رغم تحررها من الحوثيين
لكنها لا تزال محاصره من ابوابها الشرقيه
خاصه
وكذلك الوضع الملتهب في مارب لا تزال جيوب
الحوثيين موجوده في صرواح وفي بعض
المديريات الشماليه من المحافظه جبهه مارب
مهمه الرئيس هذه اليوم يمارس عمله على
ترابه الوطني على
ارضه ليس كما قيل بالامس رئيس في المنفى
وبالمناسبه عندما قال الناطق الرئاسي بان
الرئيس هادي سوف يصلي العيد في في عدن في
اليمن تندر وكاله الانباء التابعه او
وسائل الاعلام عفوا التابعه للانقلابيين
بان الامام البدر وهو اخر امام في اليمن
عندما غادر من صنعاء قال لانصاره بانه
سيعود وسيصل العيد في صنعاء ولم يعد حتى
مات في المنفى وهذا ما كانوا يتنبؤون به
لهذه لكنه كسر هذه
المعادله بفعل عده عوامل ليس هنا مجال ذك
اكثر من نقطه سيد جميح من خلال هذه العوده
لكن الان مع ضيفنا السيد عبد الناصر
العربي من عدن نود ان انف فهم يعني غير
الرمزيه تحدث ضيفنا من لندن عن ترتيب
لملفات ذكر الملف الامني ثم الملف عفوا
الملف الانساني هو يعني ذكره في البدايه
الامني ومن ثم العسكري وكلها ملفات ملحه
على جدول اعمال الرئيس هادي لكن الى جانب
رمزيه هذه الخطوه واهميه هذه الخطوه بعوده
الرئيس الى عدن اين ال الاستراتيجي في ما
اقدم عليه اي ا اهميه تكتسيها ربما
الخطوات الاستراتيجيه والفعليه على واقع
الارض التي يمكن فعليا ان يقوم بها وكيف
السبيل
لتحقيقها
ا اولا اريد ان اعرق على ما طرحه اخي من
لندن محمد جميح وكلامه صحيح بان هناك
ملفين رئيسيين يعتبران من اهم الملفات
والملفات الشائكه التي ستكون مثقله على
رئيس الجمهوريه والحكومه اليمنيه وهما
بالتدرج او بالتلازم
قد اختلف مع اخي من من لندن بان الملف
الاغاثي قبل الامني لكن الملف الامني يوحي
لنا بانه لابد ان يكون في
مقدمه لابد ان يكون ثم الملف الملف
الاغاثي ذا اولويه فعلا اما الرمزيه التي
التي نتحدث عنها والاستراتيجيه الذي التي
بدات هو وصول رئيس الجمهوريه تعتبر النقطه
المفصليه اي الى الارض اليمنيه والتي كان
هناك نوع من التحدي بان رئيس الجمهوريه لا
يستطيع ان يمارس عمله كرئيس شرعي من ارض
محرره ونحن الان لسنا امام ارض صغيره
محرره ولكن الان محافظات تتحرر تدريجيا
وتتدحرج ك ك كالكره التي تلتهم من يحاول
ان يعطل ثوره الحياه او عاده التغيير
البعد الاستراتيجي الذي يقوم به رئيس
الجمهوريه هو مهم جدا باحياء عمليه
الامن واستتباب الامن ليس على مستوى
المحافظات المحرره ولكن يبعثه كرساله
قادمه في الافق للمحافظات الاخرى ونحن
الان امام معضله حقيقيه في الملف الامني
قبل
الاغاثي بان عدن ما زالت تحتاج نوع من
التامين من المدن المحرره تحتاج نوع من
التامين نجد ان من جهه من جهه الشرق عندما
نرى في ما بعد معسكر لبوزه ومنطقه الشريقه
هناك هناك منبع خطر موجود نؤكد عليه بانه
لابد ان يكون له تنبه
كبير المساله الاستراتيجيه التي قد نقف
عليها بشكل صحيح وجدي هو مع الجانب الامني
والاغاثه واعاده الناس الى الى الى
مساكنهم ومرتبط هذا كله في الجانبين
الامني والاغاثه هو مساله كيف يتم
دمج المقاومه الشعبيه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الوطني الجديد الجيش الوطني الذي نعتبره
اساسيه خارجه عن اطار السلال نعم سنعود
حتما سيد عبد الناصر بالنقاش الى هذه
النقطه وغيرها من النقاط لكن سنذهب الان
الى فاصل قصير سنناقش ب ما الذي يمكن ان
تحققه عوده هادي الى عدن على الصعيدين
الميداني والسياسي في الفتره المقبله
ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نسلط فيها الضوء على مغزى وانعكاسات وصول
الرئيس اليمني عبد الربو منصور هادي الى
عدن بعد غياب دام قرابه سته اشهر اعود الى
ضيفي الكريمين تحديدا الى لندن والسيد
جميح يعني ضيفنا منذ قليل تحدث عن ضروره
توحيد القوه سمعنا هذه عندما عاد ونقلت
عنه وكاله سبانت قوله بالحرف الواحد ان
العوده الى العاصمه صنعاء ستكون قريبا بعد
ان يتم تحرير كافه المدن والمحافظات من
الميليشيا الانقلابيه نود ان نقف قليلا
عند قريبا ما الذي تعنيه تحديدا على مستوى
توحيد هذه القوى المطلوب و توحيد الاهداف
للوصول لنتائج ملموسه في نهايه الامر على
الارض طبعا من ضمن سلبيات العمل المقاوم
في الشهور المنصرمه سلبيه كانت ظاهره
وواضحه العيان هي سلبيه غياب التنسيق
ووجود العمل العشوائي غير المنظم كانت
هناك مقاومات مختلفه ولم تكن هناك مقاومه
موحده نظرا طبعا لعده عوامل ياتي في مق
مقدمتها غياب القياده العسكريه اعتقال
وزير
الدفاع
تاخر قرار جمهوري بتعيين رئيس الاركان وما
الى ذلك لكن كانت هناك مقاومه في تعز هناك
مقاومه منعزله في مارب وهناك ايضا كانت
مقاومه منعزله في عدن وفي الضالع وفي
غيرها من
المحافظات الان وجود الرئيس سيتيح فرصه
اعاده توحيد هذه المقاومات المختلفه
ودمجها في الاجهزه الامنيه واعاده بناء
الجيش الوطني على اسس وطنيه لا على اسس
سلاليه ولا على اسس طائفيه ولا على اسس
فرديه تتبع شخصيه الزعيم او
الرئيس اذا ما توفرت هذه الخطوه واعتقد
انها ستسير متساو لانه لا ينبغي ان ينتظر
الفعل المقاوم الى ان تتوحد د الاراده
المقاومه بل على الفعل المقاوم ان يعمل
عملهم وبالتساوي تسير الاراده المقاومه
ازاء توحيد المكونات المخ الم عده هذه
يمكن فعلا ان ان تساعد في هذا الاتجاه
باعتقادك عوده هذه ستعطي دفعه قويه رمزيه
ومعنويه ونفسيه للمقاومين هذا اولا عوده
هذه عوده رئيس الدوله ستضفي ايضا مزيدا من
الشرعيه على هذه المقاومات هذه المقاومات
المختلفه هنا وهناك وجدت الان المظله
الوطنيه التي يمكنها ان تحتمي بها وان
تدخل في اطارها وان تكون ممثله بها
وبالتالي ايضا عوده هذه مهمه على المستوى
الاداري للدوله على مستوى اصدار الاوامر
على مستوى القرب من المقاومين على مستوى
الالتحام بالفعل مقاوم على الارض كل هذه
عوامل مهمه وان كنا لا ندركها على يعني في
المدى القريب او خلال الايام لكنها مهمه
لنفسيات المقاومين مهمه ايضا لقطع
الاقاويل والالسنه التي تتحد حدث هنا
وهناك عن وجود خلافات هنا وهناك بين
المقاومين او بين المقاومه والقياده
السياسيه او بين المقاومه والقياده
السياسيه من جهه وقوات التحالف من جهه
اخرى عوده هذه في تصوره ستقطع كثيرا من
الاقاويل والتسريبات التي يتعمد معسكر
صالح والحوثي ان يسرب من اجل ارباك العمل
المقاوم في البلاد ا سيد عبد الناصر يعني
الرئيس هادي في اجتماعه مع اعضاء الحكومه
تحدث عن ضروره ان تقوم هذه الحكومه
بمراجعه
المواضيع الملحه بالنسبه للسكان الصحه
الماء الكهرباء خاصه في عدن الجميع يعلم
الوضع الماساوي للاسف هناك ما الذي يمكن
باعتقادك ان يحققه وصول الرئيس اليمني الى
عدن في هذا السياق وانت كنت قد تحدثت
وفضلت ان تكون الاولويه امنيه وعسكريه عن
الجانب
الانساني في حقيقه الامر رئيس الجمهوريه
يعتبر بوصله رئيسيه لل للشرعيه والى لما
قام هذا الصراع بيننا وبين هذه الفئه
الضاله فئه الانقلابيين المتواجدين
والقابع في صنعاء والان المحصورين في
صنعاء يعتبر رئيس الجمهوريه هو البوصله
الحقيقيه التي ممكن توجه من خلال
التوجيهات الحقيقيه الخطيه للحكومه بان
يكون هناك عمليه تنفيذ لاننا نرى ان هناك
حديثا وليس هناك تنفيذ في بعض القضايا
والحكومه عليها يعني على اي سعيد تتحدث
حتى نفهم فقط على اي صعيد الصعيد الامني
ام على الصعيد الاغاثي والانساني واعاده
الاعمار انا ا اتكلم على على كافه الاصعده
وهناك امثله كثيره معيبه نرجو ان لا
نظهرها للعل نرجو ان تكون موجوده على
السطح ولكن لابد ان تعالج اولا باول كي
يلمسها المواطن المواطن اذا لم يلمس هناك
عمليه اغاث وعمليه امنيه وعمليه معالجه
جرحى او عوده الى منازلهم او تامين لا
يمكن ان ان يصدق هذه الحكومه ولذلك جاء
رئيس الجمهوريه ليؤكد هذا الشيء وينفي كل
الاشاعات التي تاتي من هنا وهناك وعلى
راسها اشاعات المخلوع وعفاش وال الحوثيين
وهنا على رئيس على رئيس الدوله مسؤوليه
كبيره لابد ان يتحملها خلال الثلاثه
الايام القادمه قبل ان يغادرنا الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليكون هناك
بصيص امل للعمل على الارض فالعمل الاغاثي
مؤلم لابد ان يكون هناك وضوح وشفافيه
للعلن كيف يتم عمليه الاغاثه هناك اسر
تاخذ مرتين وهناك اسر لا تاخذ شيء وهناك
اسر معزوله في مناطق خلا موجوده في هذا
المكان الجغرافي المكون من اقليم عدن الذي
تم تحريره ولا بد من استكمال تامينه من اي
خطر ليس خطر فقط الحوثيين ولكن هناك خطر
ان يكون هناك نشوء فئات ضاله من تهدي بنا
من دربنا الحقيقي الذي لابد من خلاله ان
نبني نذهب الى درب فرعي يهدر الطاقه التي
قمنا عليها وعلى رئيس الجمهوريه انا اؤكد
بان رئيس الجمهوريه عليه ان يرفع القبعه
ويقول شكرا للمقاومه ولكن بالتاكيد نحن
نقول ان المقاومه ليست بديله عن السلطه
وعلى السلطه ان يكون لها جمع في حزام واحد
لهذه المقاومه لتكون اطارها الجيش والامن
وارجو هناك نقطه اريد ان اضيفها كما اتخذ
قرار فيما يخص الجانب الامني والعسكري
نامل ان يكون هناك قرار يخص الجانب المدني
لان هناك من كانوا يقاتلوا على الميدان
وهم مقاومون هم في الاصل اطباء ومهندسين
ودكاتره ولكنهم ليس لديهم وظائف ونامل ان
يكون هناك قرار لياخذ هذا
الحيز بقدر من الجد اكثر من نقطه تحدثت
عنها دعني احولها لضيفنا من لندن سيد محمد
جميح اذا عاد هادي وقبله بايام عاد بحاح
لكن ماذا بعد سمعت لما ذكره ضيفنا من عدن
العديد من التحديات العديد من الملفات
وعلى اكثر من
صعيد طبعا الامر يعني ليس ورديا كما يمكن
ان يصور ولا احد يقول ذلك يعني عوده هذه
هي بدايه الطريق اها الذي يفترض ان ينتهي
في صعده وهذه طريق شاق لا شاق
لابد ان اقول ذلك محفوفه بكثير من المخاطر
كثير من التحديات
والصعاب انا في تصوري ان واحده من من
المسائل التي ينبغي التركيز عليها هي وحده
القياده السياسيه خلال الايام الماضيه
تحدث الكثير عن وجود خلافات بين الرئيس
ونائبه بين بعض الوزراء اذا لم تحسم هذه
المساله فانها ستشكل ماده دسمه
للانقلابيين للعمل عليها والاشتغال عليها
وافساد المرحله لابد من ا يعني وجود
الاختلاف في الاراء والتوجهات لا يلغي
حقيقه ان هذه قياده سياسيه واحده وان
الاهداف واحده وان الهدف الرئيس من عاصفه
الحزم واعاره الامل قد تحقق بعوده الشرعيه
الى ارض البلاد وان بقيه الاشياء هي مجرد
تفاصيل لا ينبغي ان
تكون حاده وحاسم في علاقات اطراف العمليه
السياسيه الشرعيه في البلاد اذا مهم ترتيب
البيت اليمني الداخلي في جانبه الشرعي من
اجل الاستعداد للحسم النهائي واستعاده
العاصمه وبقيه المحافظات هناك ايضا ملفات
اخرى ربما مظلومه لا تطرح بشكل مستمر ملف
الجرحه جرح المقاومه الشعبيه في كل
المحافظات يعانون من كثير من الاهمال بل
انهم بالاضافه الى معاناتهم الجسديه
يعانون ايضا من المعاناه النفسيه نتيجه
الاهمال ونتيجه لبعض الالفاظ التي تصدر في
حقهم من هنا هنا وهناك هذا هؤلاء لا ينبغي
وهم اكرمنا جميعا وهم انبل جميعا لا ينبغي
ان يعاملوا بهذه المعامله ينبغي على
القياده السياسيه في البلد ان توليهم
الاعتبار الاول لانهم هم الذين ضحوا
بدمائهم قبل غيرهم من الذين يعني اداروا
العمليه السياسيه ملفات كثيره ملف التنسيق
بين المقا كثير ذكرت بعضا منها دعنا نتحول
في ربما اقل من دقيقه ومعه نختم السيد عبد
الناصر العربي وهو من ع
وربما انت تقف على الاوضاع هناك باعتقادك
هذهه الحكومه الان ما المطلوب منها ان كان
لنا ان نضع نقاطا واحد اثنان ثلاثه ما
المطلوب الان حتى فعلا يكتمل الهدف الاكبر
في نهايه الامر ولا يخص يقتصر الموضوع على
عوده الرئيس الى عدن
وانتهى انا سقسم الموقف الى الى قسمين
القسم الاصغر والقسم الاكبر القسم الاصغر
هو ان يتم العمل بشكل جدي
من خلال هذه المناطق المحرره ليكون تاكيد
الى المستوى الاكبر اللي هو القسم الاخر
وهو كيف يتم الوصول الى صعده والى صنعاء
وتحرير هذه المناطق هي بالاصل تامين لعدن
واقليم عدن نحن نؤكد بان على
الحكومه استراتيجيا و تكتيكيا في الفتره
الانيه ليكون لديها استراتيجيه في
المستقبل ان تبقى وت مستمر كعناصر وكحك ان
يكون هناك نوع من الشفافيه والوضوح في
جانب الاعمار والاغاثه وجانب عمليه دمج
المقاومه بالذات في الاطار المدني
والعسكري لان هناك نتوءات نتمنى انلا تظهر
ونعمل على المؤسسه بشكل المؤسسه بشكل نقول
وطني وخلاق اشكرك جزيل الشكر عبد الناصر
العربي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا
من لندن كما نشكر جزي الشكر السيد محمد
جميح الكاتب والباحث السياسي اليمني من
لندن ختام حلقتنا هذه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد كل عام وانتم بالف خير
والسلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه